all right we're going to talk to angie
thomas
why she became an international
phenomenon back in 2017
after the remarkable success of her
debut novel is called the hate u give
it has been on the new york times
bestseller list for more than 200 weeks
you go angie thomas it was adapted into
a hit movie
actors amandala stenberg and russell
hornsby portrayed sixteen-year-old star
carter and her father
maverick now her new novel concrete rose
brings readers back to the origin of the
story maverick carter
17 years before the events of the hate u
give
angie thomas joins us now for an
interview she's in mississippi
for a story that you'll see first on cbs
this morning
good to see you angie thomas
thank you so much for having me yeah you
got big reason to smile because
you know the hate you give was so
successful did you think you know
i need to go back and revisit those
characters was that always your
intention to go back and do
a prequel it wasn't
i thought i was done with these
characters for good
what happened i wrote the end on the
hate you give yeah my readers that's
what happened
when i went out on the road to promote
the hate you give i was surprised to
learn
that my readers wanted to know about
starr's dad
maverick the most sometimes more than
they wanted to know about star
um and the hate you give we see him as
this father um
who is very active in his kids lives as
this outstanding
pillar in the community but we also know
that he has a past
um he he talks about it and they give
how he once sold drugs and he was once
in a gang
and people always ask me how did he
become the person we see in the hate you
give
and i felt that the best way to answer
their questions was to write a book
yes i mean i was so surprised when i
started reading i went hey this goes
back to the other story
was there also something you know
because you talk about different
layers of black men's stories which i
also thought was interesting
it was and it almost seemed that you
were saying that
it can be complicated it can be layered
but there's a big foundation
of black men who they are and why they
are
i thought this was a very important
thing you were also telling angie
absolutely absolutely we see so many
instances now where black men and black
boys aren't humanized
um they're killed because they're seen
more as threats
as things that go bump in the night and
not as full human beings
um and as an author i understand the
importance of what i do
and and how it can help shape
perspectives and and change bias
um so when writing maverick i'm writing
this young man yeah who
has done what people would call quote
unquote stereotypical things yeah
he's in the gang and yeah he sells drugs
but also
he's a young man who wants to be
protected i think that's something we
can all
identify with as human beings he's a
young man who wants to help his mom out
and provide for his family
that's something we can all identify
with so as an author i try to look at
the whys and show the people
rather than the issues or the
stereotypes it's a wise you also talk
about the vulnerabilities angie talk
about that for a second
i was very very touched by that
yeah there are a lot of scenes in
concrete roads where we see maverick
being vulnerable
um we see him crying and you would think
oh that's
you know that's just a person that's a
human being but so often society makes
black boys feel as if they can't cry
they can't be vulnerable
and that goes hand in hand with
dehumanizing them yeah
and again as an author it's part of my
responsibility
to show human beings so i i wanted
scenes in there where he cries in fact i
had so many black men and black boys
tell me please show him crying please
show those things
because people think we're not capable
of that yeah
and it's sad that this is like a bare
minimum thing
black men and black boys are asking for
for me as an author and i figured that's
the least i can do yes black men have
feelings
there's a great line of the book where
you said sometimes one person's hero
is another person's monster
yes i think we're seeing proof of that
lately
um but it's about perspective it's about
perspective
and maverick says that um in reference
to an incident that happens
in his community he also says it in
reference to his father
um who was known around the neighborhood
for being a gang legend
and had he been on the news had his mug
shot been on the news
people would assume oh this is a monster
this is a monster this is a heartless
man
but for maverick he was his father from
maverick that was his hero
maverick he was so much more than a mug
shot
and we we don't nearly talk about human
beings
enough when it comes to um when we see
people
who've committed crimes we don't talk
about the human element enough
and as a writer that it has on children
it's part of my responsibility and the
fact that
that it has on children you say listen
even the murderers have families who
care about them and the fact that
going to prison what that how that
affects the family
your book is very layered yes we don't
talk about kids enough
your book is very layered listen we were
watching you when tony was doing his
chicken story
we saw you angie thomas you were
laughing you seem to have some thoughts
do you want to vote for our favorite
fried chicken just because we saw you
laughing
i yeah i will have to say that for
mississippi
the best fried chicken is not at a fast
food restaurant
fighting work trying to find a good hole
in the wall joint in mississippi
to get the good fried chicken don't do
popeyes
no those are fighting words you want to
name the place in mississippi
what is it yeah well there
are several elections give me one two
sisters
two sisters two sisters okay all right
i'm in mississippi i'm going there
angie thomas thank you the name of the
book concrete rose goes on sale
hey where's the title come from quickly
concrete rose what is that
it comes from it comes from a tupac poem
called the rose that grew from congress
yes yes yes
all right thank you thank you very much
angie always good to see you
gail i can't believe you still didn't
think i like fried chicken it's like not
liking dogs or laughing
no i just no i just asked i just wanted
to be sure
because i've never seen you you don't
like smiling